good evening everybody my name is
Wilfred Wars I lives in lose today I'm
trying to get an exclusive interview
with the world-famous Slender Man now if
only he would cut out of hiding like a
little [ __ ] baby that he is out of his
little was there but perhaps we could
find some clues to his whereabouts
later on excuse me Worf that seems to be
clearing up a little bit all over
himself oh we seem to be in a bit of a
woods area here so let's just continue
on until we can find where the
Slenderman hides in war huh it appears
we've come across a rather strange tree
although it doesn't seem to be anything
particularly odd about it but hopefully
there will be some Wow let's see here
we've got a diary from up very mr.
Slenderman hmm gee a splendor now he's
rested to himself how adorable a
beautiful Enderman today I saw him he
looks so gorgeous Val with his long
flowing mohawk and his kin tiling
muscular build this one that I love so
dearly a mr. markiplier well it seems
that the Slender Man is a romantic
interest that we need to interview him
about ha ha ha what a [ __ ] ah here's
another page of a slender man Oh spirit
Oh No this markiplier has been stealing
my channel places but that doesn't
matter because markiplier senpai will
notice me someday ooh goo it just goes
on for a while just a goo
Guu uguu you you I don't know what that
means
well it seems that we've come across
some sort of a elementary school
building where I'm feel that the
Slenderman spends most of his time cuz
we all know that he molest children and
jazz heroine in this location so
hopefully you'll be able to provide some
clues as a what he's been doing with all
this children's and heroine hmm mmm is
taking Worf tossed quite some time to be
able to find these Basil's of the
slander that he hides it well but not as
well as a heroin stash which warped a
skull in through a little bit oh that's
why Wolf's ass feels a little extra
happy in this interview that we're
having with well ourselves right now
because the Slenderman will not show up
well there's no pages in Silas house
dariya let's go our science see if we
can find a clue I still worry about of
those missing children and as well as
flenders missing hair if you know what I
mean haha Oh lost this the things that
we have founded over one of the slender
man's pages of cystine asst holstee oku
wickles again for a while just a gooing
all over the place Oh
markiplier picked up my pace that
confessed my love to him and yet no
avail he has now responded to my I you
and then it rambles on for quite a bit
oh how I wish you would let me just
slide my two old I whoa that gets a
little bit graphic their slender my
and if if I do say Oh mr. Slenderman are
you hiding in the woods please I need to
give you an exclusive interview mr.
Slender Man slender man are you there
he's disappeared again he's probably
none too happy that I'm reading his
private journal pages however I'm sure
that he wouldn't mind us announcing his
love for this markiplier to the entire
world
oh hello we seem to have come across
another page of mr. Slenderman diary
more like verbal diarrhea ha ha ha Oh
mr. Slenderman are you there Jimmy don't
run away from the truth mr. Slenderman
where did you get a diction to your
stupid hairstyle or life lack thereof
willful Wolf's ass doesn't know where to
find the other pages but willful dwarf
ass will keep going until the day that
Wilfred wolf - dies because that's the
kind of journalistic integrity that
Wilfred Wolf's ass has he will not stop
until they're my boss - boy but I he
will not stop until those intrusive than
found oh I was just told by my news
station that Wilfred Wolf's - did not
read the last note I said well very
plainly war Shasta's mustache is stupid
why did you say to me you son of a [ __ ]
what that don't take [ __ ] from nobody
I'm gonna come there and shall be a
tentacles
so far up your ass you'll never be able
to see the light of day
what does spinning quite profusely again
well once again willful dwarfs - and as
news
through a wandering the woods trying to
find the truth about the slender man
without talking them because that guy is
kind of a dick
oh hello mr. Slenderman are you out
there I've got a back of my hand
introduce to you black that's gonna not
feel very good unlike what you want to
do to miss the mark of wire oh well well
Wow what do we have here the Slenderman
gigantic red dildo dild old device
otherwise known as a dildo haha let's
read what it says here
oh how I wish well this dildo could be
markiplier real I would imagine myself
oh well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen this lemon didn't very much
appreciate us finding his Zillow and
reading his diary PLAs you see he's
still a bastard if the dicks of the
heroin and molest children's oh this is
where we'll
lousy news good night here creature and
all of is listed all a registered sex
offender and heroin addict Scoob a
clever man could we get an interview
where did it all go so
oh good evening everybody my name is
will for a long time